[Music]
today crews in louisiana are working to
reach
some of the hardest hit damage left by
hurricane laura
starting the cleanup there and one of
the strongest storms to ever hit the u.s
this is a look at just some of the
damage in grand lake louisiana
that's just a few miles from where the
storm made landfall in cameron
at least six people in the state are
dead tony decouple has been reporting
from us
from hard hit lake charles since the
moment the storm came ashore he's still
there today
tony what do things look like where you
are hey good morning guys unfortunately
down just about every street here in
lake charles there is damage
particularly down
power lines and there is a distinct
checkerboard effect to the damage of
as well and you can really take it in if
you go above it all take a look at this
you'll notice that one structure will be
completely gone and then the next it
will appear
is almost entirely unscathed and on top
of that
there is a strange precision to this
storm along one of the main roads in
town i noticed a bridal shop
with the roof ripped off but all the
wedding dresses inside
still on the hangers and just not a far
walk from where i'm standing right this
moment there's an apartment building
with the facade ripped off but inside on
the kitchen table there was a pier
there was what appeared to be salt and
pepper shakers even a box
of napkins if you can believe that but
if you really want to take in the scale
and the damage here in southern
louisiana you're going to need a much
larger flying machine and that's why
omar villafranca boarded a helicopter
to survey the destruction for us in hard
hit cameron louisiana
hurricane laura made landfall near here
in
cameron louisiana and the town is
virtually
unrecognizable if the wind didn't
destroy it
it is now covered in water we're about
200 feet
in the air and everywhere you look
there is damage it's hard to find a
place that has not been affected
by hurricane laura you see trees snapped
and
smashed on top of homes cars that have
just been thrown down the street
and you're also seeing pieces of
people's homes and memories
spread in neighbor's yard it may
take weeks or months to clean all this
up
harrowing pictures there in cameron
louisiana that was omar via franco
reporting for us and gayle and anthony
i want to mention also that it seems
that sometimes hurricanes and politics
collide as well
in front of the courthouse here in lake
charles there is a confederate statue
which local officials recently voted to
keep in its place that was a
controversial choice
hurricane laura had other ideas though
knocked it right off its pedestal
anthony very interesting tony thank you
very much